that one with the bishop or the knight
which one would you block uh with the
with a knight
my first instinct would be knight
because the knights are king's best
friend just kind of tuck it away
keep the king nice and safe but if you
can't use your knight later in the game
um well you might want to centralize it
yeah a bit later on that's true so if
you can't use your knight in the game
then you have to actually retreat with a
bishop so
bishops are long-range pieces so maybe
it's better to plant a bishop further
back in the box okay he's gone for the
night's best friend approach
and uh okay and we have to remember that
hikaru
is in a must-win situation ah dagness is
winning now
hikaru's just blundered he avoided the
queen trade but he's put his queen on a
square
protecting the bishop in the corner now
the queen's attacked there's no way to
save white's bishop in the corner
nakamura resigns wow what an ending
to the first day and the final hikaru
nagamura
plundering magnus carlson winning the
second game of today for him
and that means he is the winner of the
the first day
in the final what a dramatic first day